on this thursday night
unwrapping ontario's boxing day lockdown
the christmas eve rush ahead of tough
new restrictions
why would you do it after the most
dangerous time as
experts forecast a tsunami of new cases
canada's vaccine strategy under scrutiny
why critics say the rollout is too slow
85 million u.s
travelers define the warnings we're only
going to get
through this okay if we abandon
selfishness
the dread over christmas being america's
new super spreader
and church services altered we're all
pivoting
keeping the faith during the pandemic
global national with
donna friesen reporting tonight robin
gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us on this christmas eve
we wish we could tell you there's some
relief from the kova 19 pandemic
but canada's two biggest provinces have
broken records for daily new infections
while people everywhere are being warned
to obey public health rules or face
devastating fallout in the new year
here's the tally in ontario today a
record shattering 2 47
cases and 49 more people have died
quebec also reported a single day high
with more than 2 300 cases
and 46 more deaths this was the sixth
day in a row quebec recorded
more than two thousand cases with fierce
hospitals could soon be overwhelmed both
ontario and quebec are headed back into
lockdown in quebec non-essential
businesses will close starting tomorrow
ontario's province-wide shutdown goes
into effect boxing day
the decision to wait until the 26th to
impose restrictions
is sparking criticism and concern mike
drillet has tonight's top story
call it the storm before the calm before
an even bigger storm
with the countdown to the lockdown
ticking away there was no holding back
the christmas frenzy
in and around toronto i was in walmart
up on eglinton this morning
that place was packed packed
it's enough to make health experts
cringe and fear the worst
a surge of christmas-fed cases of covet
19
unlike anything ontario's healthcare
system has seen before
dr anna banerjee worries the province's
intensive care units will be overwhelmed
with what she says will be a tsunami of
new cases in january
which biostatistician ryan imgram
predicts a new modeling
will translate into an extra 10 000 new
cases
over the next month i fail to understand
why it was started on the 26th other
than it being potentially political so
if you're going to impose a lockdown why
would you do it
after the most dangerous time why indeed
ford says he ordered the five-day delay
to allow businesses to offload inventory
and besides he says he still urges
ontarians to lay off the big family
dinners
no i'm not compromising anything public
health officials had warned in the fall
that if the number of covid19 patients
in ontario icu surpassed 150
surgeries would have to be cancelled
there are now nearly 300 patients in
icus
and the province's modeling suggests
that in the worst case scenario
there could be demand for over 1500 icu
beds by mid-january
if ontarians don't heed the social
distancing warnings
banerjee says ontario just doesn't have
enough icu doctors
nurses and ventilators to treat that
many
if there's no place for them to go
you've got a healthy 50 year old
who's you know been healthy their whole
life and they get coveted and all of a
sudden
you know it's it's affecting their lungs
if there's no icu
or no ventilator machine
then they will die similar scenarios
played out earlier this year with
tragic results in new york and italy
hopefully history
doesn't repeat itself mike durley global
news toronto
in the prime minister's christmas
message to canadians he acknowledges
this holiday season will be difficult
and he's urging people to focus on the
positives
we can all agree that 2020 has been a
tough year
but through it we've seen canadians meet
these challenging times
with generosity kindness and hope
so today and into the new year let's
continue to stand together
let's support folks in need in our
communities and let's reach out to our
friends and neighbors who may be having
a tough time
and some good news on the vaccine front
one day after health canada approval
the first modernity doses are now on
canadian soil this was toronto pearson
airport today
the government says the modernist shots
will begin arriving in the territories
on december 28th there are questions
tonight about how canada's vaccines are
being ruled out
some provinces are reserving half the
doses they receive
so the first recipients get their second
shot in time
but new data suggests candidate could be
better off if all doses were rolled out
to as many people as possible abigail
beeman explains
south africa has seen 14 000 new
coronavirus cases in the past
24 hours and 400 deaths the health
department believes a new variant is
behind the surge
different from the uk's new strain you
no longer any sickness that we know is
covered all the time
nigeria is now reporting a new strain of
its own
in canada vaccines are coming health
canada approved its second this week
both require two doses so what's the
best way to roll them out
two new studies were presented to
ontario's science advisory table this
week
both presentations came to the
conclusion that
that they're front loading the doses and
not reserving
some of the installments a second doses
would be the more efficient strategy
one study showed withholding fewer doses
could prevent between
25 and 40 percent of symptomatic covid19
infections
compared to reserving half the doses bc
is among the provinces which has said it
won't
reserve i have a real challenge leaving
vaccine in the fridge when there are so
many people at risk right now but
ontario and others have said they will
reserve the second doses over supply
chain concerns ontario's ministry of
health tells global news
while some people may have good immunity
after only one dose
it's not guaranteed and a second dose is
necessary
we have enough doses in hand at this
point
that we could partially protect most of
the people in long-term care in ontario
dr david fitzman says vaccine should not
sit on shelves but he wants to be clear
a second dose is still needed when you
look at the trial data what you see is
there's a lot of protection in people
already after just the one dose and that
may wear off
you know in a few weeks time and that's
why we want them to get the second dose
but at a time when a lot of folks are
getting sick and dying from this disease
the idea is to get it into as many
different people
as we can the national advisory
committee on immunization
also tackled the question of reserving
doses in new recommendations released
wednesday
it looked at all kinds of related
ethical questions and determined each
province should make its own decision
based on its own analysis and context
including considering any unintended
consequences that could happen
if a second dose is delayed robin
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
kova 19 cases are soaring across the
united kingdom
according to the office for national
statistics one in 85 people in england
has the virus
it's believed half of all new cases
could be the new more contagious strain
london is the country's coven 19 hot
spot it has the highest percentage of
people testing positive
infections are also growing in wales and
northern ireland
but in scotland the percentage of people
with covenant 19 has dropped
to one in 140.
trucks are once again moving across the
english channel so far only three out of
more than 2300 truck drivers
have tested positive for covet 19. they
must receive a negative test result to
enter france from britain
the new rule has resulted in thousands
of truck drivers being stuck along one
of the uk's most important trade routes
the backlog is expected to take days to
clear
there is finally an end to the brexit
saga the uk has reached a deal with the
european union
the agreement comes 1645 days after
britain's voted to leave the eu
the referendum was contentious 48
voted to remain brexit forced two
british prime ministers to resign
david cameron in 2016 and theresa may
in 2019. boris johnson took over leading
the country
and brexit negotiations and as crystal
gomezing explains tonight
he's celebrating a major win
one tweet four words seven days before
deadline
getting a trade deal done wasn't easy
but on christmas eve
prime minister boris johnson delivered
for the first time
since 1973 we will be an independent
coastal state with full control
of our waters with the uk's share of
fish in our waters rising substantially
from roughly
half today to closer to two-thirds
in five and a half years time the prime
minister's thai
choice shows his dedication to fishing
rights
it was a pillar of the leave campaign
but a bit of a red herring
the fishing industry accounts for less
than one percent of the uk's economy
still it was a sticking point during
talks at the end of a successful
negotiations
journey i normally feel joy
but today i only feel
quite satisfaction and frankly speaking
relief the deal grants the uk access to
one of the largest free trade blocs in
the world
in return britain agreed to what's known
as the level playing field
adherence to environmental and worker
standards laid out by the european union
although we have left the eu this
country
will remain culturally emotionally
historically strategically geologically
attached to europe
the opposition labor leader says the
deal offers no protection for financial
services manufacturing
or creative industries it is not the
deal
that the government promised far from it
the deal still needs to be approved by
eu nations and the uk government
johnson expects a vote will take place
here on december thirtieth
after that the pressure is on the prime
minister and his conservatives to unveil
a vision for britain
now that it has a deal to continue
working with eu member states
and the freedom to branch out and build
other bridges
robin crystal germain singh in london
thanks crystal
in italy a nationwide lockdown is in
effect for much of the christmas and new
year holiday as the government looks to
prevent a fresh surge in kova 19 cases
in rome police set up roadblocks to
filter the few cars driving along the
empty streets
residents are banned from traveling from
region to region italy's total
confirmed coveted cases have now
surpassed the 2 million mark
it will begin its vaccination program on
sunday
flying in the face of countless warnings
coming up the flurry of activity
at america's airports
[Music]
let santa do the traveling for you this
christmas
that's the message from the federal
government it launched an 850
000 ad campaign that features a series
of videos urging people
particularly snowbirds to avoid
non-essential travel outside canada
the ads will run until march which is
the peak of the spring break travel
season
tens of millions of americans are
traveling across the u.s despite
restrictions in over 20 states
there are fears the holiday rush will
result in a surge of covet infections
more than 326 000 americans have been
killed by this virus
and the projections put the death toll
at over half a million by april
so there's a push to get the vaccine out
to as many as possible
here's jennifer johnson ignoring
repeated warnings from the u.s centers
for disease control and prevention
an estimated 85 million americans are on
the move this christmas time
one traveler was shocked at what she saw
at chicago's o'hare airport
if you could see my mouth i was gasping
because i it's big
there's a lot of people here experts
fear this holiday may be a real-time
super spreader event shopping malls have
been packed even in los angeles county
while there are no icu beds in all of
southern california
certain stores that we wanted to go to
were like two hour long lines
doctors are horrified at scenes of
packed crowds as new cases of cove 19 in
california push
past the 2 million mark the first state
to record such staggering numbers
i expect to see some of those folks in
our hospital
and it's only going to add to the
numbers that we're already seeing
over 100 thousand americans are spending
this christmas eve in the hospital
battling covet 19. we're only going to
get through
this okay if we abandon selfishness
operation warp speed is working to get
as many people vaccinated as quickly as
possible
over a million first doses have already
been administered
officials say they're ahead of the curve
we are on track
to allocate another four and a half to
five million
next week which will bring us to 20
million doses
of vaccine allocated to america before
the end of the year
many on the front lines are going on the
offensive in pittsburgh former steelers
football player mike logan who had covet
19 in june
is joining health care workers going
door to door encouraging residents to
get vaccinated
the moderna vaccine was created by an
african-american woman did not know that
yeah i know that's on the ground the
federal government just purchased
another 100 million doses
of the pfizer biontech vaccine as
hospitals brace for the post-holiday
weeks ahead
jennifer johnson global news washington
america's top doctor turns 80 today
happy birthday to you happy birthday
and the biden serenaded dr anthony fauci
online washington's mayor also
proclaimed christmas eve to be dr fauci
day recognizing his tireless work to
save lives
and guide america's response in the
pandemic fauci is celebrating by doing
what he has advised millions of
americans to do this holiday season
he's staying home still ahead christmas
services
switched up as governor 19 restrictions
ramp up
for the holidays
[Music]
they look more like a construction crew
but that's actually the choir of the
notre dame cathedral
holding a special christmas eve concert
for the first time since that
devastating
fire in april 2019. the singers
performed beneath the cathedral stained
glass windows standing apart
so they could take off their masks and
sing
churches around the world are changing
how they host christmas services
and there is one consistent theme
despite the pandemic bringing on our
darkest hour
there are messages of hope travis
dunroch reports
the pews at this toronto church have
been empty for weeks now
and christmas eve will be no different
this isn't the kind of stuff they train
you for in seminary but
we're all pivoting and we're all
learning still reverend jeff rock of the
metropolitan community church of toronto
says the celebrations will continue
the church usually hosts a huge evening
mass at roy thompson hall
they will again this year but this time
it will be virtual
the message after a year of loss and
struggle
is one of optimism and hope in this
tough year of 2020
that christmas story resonates all the
more about hope and the toughest of
times
and finding peace in the midst of
conflict
the spirit of goodwill is also being
spread here at the good shepherd
ministry
it's a shame that we're not able to not
able to come in and sit down but
we're still handing out the turkey meals
on christmas day and
then the roast beef on boxing day the
usually bustling kitchen is still busy
the meals for the homeless this year
packaged for takeout
we've been providing seven eight hundred
meals every day sometimes up to one
thousand
so the need it continues to increase the
need continues to grow
the ministry thankful for help big and
small nikhil
behetto and his friends collected a few
hundred dollars and decided to donate 50
meals
a lot of people are facing hardships and
i think just giving back to the
community and giving from the heart is a
good thing to do
in the midst of the pandemic streets in
bethlehem are near empty
as are churches
[Music]
carols at church services in india sung
wearing masks
at the vatican the usual sea of faithful
in saint peter's square
was replaced with a much smaller mass
inside presided over by the pope
toronto's archbishop cardinal thomas
collins says while some parishes not in
lockdown
will be able to have services with 30
percent capacity limits and covert 19
protocols in place
100 in lockdown zones will live stream
christmas eve mass
but i will in a very particular way be
offering this mass
for all of those who are suffering in
the midst of this pandemic
physically through sickness their
families for those who have died
for those who have lost their jobs for
others who are facing great affliction
during this time the carol silent night
will have new meaning this year
as celebrations at churches like this
one and around the world
adapt to the new reality of 2020 and
covet 19.
and so on this christmas eve that old
carol
silent night will have new meaning as
churches like this one
and those around the world adjust to the
new reality of 2020
and covet 19. robin travis don raj in
toronto thanks travis
up next three generations of royals and
their special gifts
on the night before christmas
it's an american christmas for the duke
and duchess of sussex their digital
portrait featuring harry megan and son
archie is based on a photo taken by the
duchess's mother
the card was released in partnership
with mayhew an animal welfare charity
that megan is a patron of it was the
night before christmas when all through
the house
not a creature charles and his wife
camilla kicked off a recital of twas the
night before christmas
a plethora of celebrity guests joined
the future king to promote the actors
benevolent fund
which helps those in the theatric world
during times of financial hardship
especially now with the pandemic the
prince of wales has been a patron of the
organization
for 20 years and finally tonight
canadian artist
stuart reynolds better known as
brittlestar has his own version of that
poem
which is formerly known as the visit
from saint nicholas and brittlestar has
just
one big christmas wish twas the night
before christmas
one last message to send dear santa
here's what i want it's to make this
stupid year end
the frontline workers all snug in their
bed
shut the hell up they all need their
rest the wife in her dressing gown
me and my mask having just received
delivery of some late night snacks
when all of a sudden on my phone there
arose such a clatter
i checked my doorbell app to see what's
the matter
what to my eggnog eyes did appear one
jolly elf
and eight tiny reindeer santa claus is
it you
i yelled opening the door it is i he
replied
i brought what you wanted what you
wanted and more
he continued the year 2020 it will soon
be done
and though it's been pretty crappy there
has been some fun
i mean grandparents on zoom that's
pretty funny
and have you ever eaten so much take out
let's ask your bulging tummy
but i digress i told you i brought more
gifts than this
i want you to think of all the things
that you've missed
the concerts the cafes a kiss on the
cheek
the hugs the handshakes no mass when we
speak
it's all coming back that's my gift to
you
it's all coming back and it's coming
back soon
ish and here's the only thing that i ask
of you
it's to be kind be considerate in the
things that you do
it might take some time you might need
to wait
but trust me when i say it's going to be
great
so for this christmas the one thing you
asked was for old saint nick
to kick 2020 right in the ass soon as he
finished
he began prepping his ride he jumped in
his sleigh
and i headed inside i stopped before he
took to the skies
i asked him hey santa do you have any
extra ps5s
he did not
and that is global national for this
christmas eve i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the festive light
display in ottawa thank you for watching
and i'll see you back here tomorrow
merry christmas and to all
a good night